okay let's get into audience questions
for the week david now with more
hindsight can we finally say
what george w bush's legacy is and how
does it compare to what you thought it
would be when he left office
this is a really interesting question i
actually see george w
bush's legacy now uh
many years out from his presidency as
exactly what i believed it would be
when george w bush left office now you
could make the case it just hasn't been
enough time we need to wait even more
time to know what george w bush's real
long-term legacy is going to be but
uh sort of around the edges from the
point of view of
uh of tone rather than substance george
w
bush was known for being sort of the
dumb president not particularly bright
i think the trump presidency has put
that in context
like at least george w bush read books
uh you know that he he was dumb-ish but
not as dumb as donald trump
on policy and failures
uh george w bush's legacy when he left
office was that of
a war criminal who went to war with the
wrong country
after the 9 11 attacks invading iraq
and starting the disaster that we now uh
know of and even have much agreement on
from many republicans
as to that war uh also
in the post-9 11 era george w bush's
legacy
is the patriot act um and the
sort of start of a progressive set not
progressive politically but a growing
and advancing
uh set of restrictions on privacy of
many kinds including via
technological means the failure on
katrina
certainly hurricane katrina one of the
main um
legacy elements of george w bush
and that's really what we believed when
george w
bush left office and this is
interesting from the standpoint of being
able to tell versus not being able to
tell
legacy relatively quickly i mean i think
the the question would be
if you went back to fdr
did we know fdr's legacy right
when when he was no longer in office
i i think looking at the contemporaneous
writing you sort of did
um getting the us and the world beyond
world war
ii and the um new deal
uh that that was widely written about at
the time and
i would argue is still the bulk of fdr's
legacy uh abraham lincoln you go back to
abraham lincoln and
quote freeing the slaves being part of
the union
around civil war times i don't know if
the term legacy was being used at the
time of
of lincoln's assassination but certainly
it was clear that that was
a big deal not everybody liked it but
that that was a big deal so
i i do think that the benefit of
hindsight is useful in thinking about
what is the legacy of a president and
the more distance you get from it the
the more important
and useful that that can be but with
george w
bush at least the his legacy was pretty
clear right away
and now as we are um
13 years out from george w bush
it has remained that way now if there
are things i'm missing that you think
are part of george w bush's legacy let
me know
and then the question becomes what is
donald trump's legacy going to be
and uh not good i think is how i would
characterize it but we'll leave
the deeper analysis for another moment